[Música]
muy buenas noches mi nombre es joe
mansilla y he venido
invitado de sido invitado para
presentarle lo que la inclusión del
hombre produce los cambios que produce
en el monte chaco santiagueño la
incursión del hombre aquel monte que se
solía llamar hasta el siglo pasado
impenetrable
el monte que
regionalmente
sobre la provincia del chaco parte de
formosa de santiago del estero y salta y
se lo llamaba impenetrable justamente
porque
el hombre que debía viajar
desde buenos aires por ejemplo hacia el
norte no lo podía cruzar era muy
peligroso en la selva cerrada con
animales salvajes además
aborígenes beligerante que como por
ejemplo los guaycurúes que era un
desprendimiento de los tobas
el monte impenetrable
hoy
no es ni salvaje ni prístino o virgen
sino
que se ha reducido por la incursión del
hombre a una pequeña porción que gracias
a dios' en el año 2017
se ha creado el parque nacional
impenetrable nuestro parque nacional más
joven de la de la nación
el parque nacional impenetrable que
pretende recuperar parte de aquella
naturaleza
prístina o virgen o salvaje que le diera
el nombre
yo les dije nací allá desde chico he
sido testigo de sus sonidos de su vida
y
también de su fisonomía de su aspecto
físico gracias a dios he podido crecer y
disfrutar también algo aunque más que
ser testigo de su estado natural es yo
testigo de su depredación
he sido testigo de cómo fue explotado en
forma exagerada podríamos decir cuando
el del siglo pasado al principio del
siglo pasado
descubren empresarios
europeos un árbol que es el rey del
monte chaco santiagueño que es el
quebracho colorado descubren que ese
árbol tiene propiedades únicas
es de una madera dura confiable e impute
facta
entonces era ideal para calzar las vías
del ferrocarril que estaban realizando
y también para extraer el tanino de su
tronco y mandarlos a europa a las
grandes fábricas textiles
entonces
comenzaron a hacer acuerdos
con gobernantes provinciales y
nacionales consiguiendo grandes
concesiones de monte por apenas nada
además la autorización para explotar
también al criollo la mano de obra sería
criolla los hacheros
y ahí entonces fue cuando toda una raza
de achero fue prácticamente esclavizado
y esa situación
perduró por más de un siglo
luego vinieron los agroganaderos con sus
topadoras
y continuaron con la depredación del
monte y ese monte ha sido
explotado y arrasado y jamás ha
reforestado
cuando se fueron los madereros
de euros y empresarios europeos
se notó que quedó una pobreza aún mayor
de la que aún esa región no se puede
recuperar
desde chico les decía me tocó ser parte
testigo de esa depredación y por eso
cuando termina el secundario
puede ir como maestro
voluntario bachiller a una escuela
rancho a varias escuelas rancho a
trabajar en medio de ese monte chaco
santiagueño
allí en escuelas ranchos como le
decíamos que son
escuela pequeñas construcciones
precarias construidas por el propio
vecino aunque ante la ausencia del
estado
el de la foto soy yo el maestro
que era bachiller y había comenzado a
realizar estudiar el magisterio luego en
otras aulas ya cuando ejerciendo como
profesor en buenos aires en el tercer
para nada y también en santiago del
estero en las aulas del secundario he
continuado con esta defensa del monte y
del hachero del trabajador forestal
incluso
en mi trabajo en el periodista que
también lo hago desde mi adolescencia
comencé a publicar siempre siempre
publicado
con respecto a este tema por ejemplo en
mi revista dni esta etapa es testigo de
mi trabajo
y un día dije cómo no era suficiente
tenemos que salir a la calle y salimos a
la calle
salimos a la calle
a mostrar a manifestarnos con algunos
colegas docentes y otros vecinos
lo más interesante del monte
son tan los sonidos cuando uno ingresa
al monte
primero se hace un silencio súbito breve
luego los animales comienzan a moverse
el viento a mover los gajos algún rugido
pájaros que cantan
y comienza de nuevo ese analizar cada
uno de los sonidos
pero lo más interesante es luego de una
lluvia
cuando se hace un silencio un silencio
profundo muy profundo tan profundo que
cala los huesos
es un silencio intenso y largo es cuando
dicen el monte está rezando el monte
reza le pide a su padre creador tal vez
que lo proteja
tal vez
que lo preserven tal vez recuperación
he pedido
he pedido a mis musas
a través de mis venas poéticas que
dejaron algunos versos para que yo
pudiera resumir esta situación que vive
nuestro monte chaco santiagueño y ella
me inspiraron para algo que quiero
compartir con usted esta noche a modo de
despedida
dice los sonidos del viento
hubo un tiempo en este monte cuando todo
era alegría con sonidos naturales en
silvestre sinfonía pero entonces vino el
hombre con sonidos diferentes
golpes de hachas motosierras y motores
estridentes y las aves espantadas
despojadas de sus nidos se quedaron en
silencio lo privaron de sus trinos fue
tan duro este silencio y tan triste para
el monte que los árboles caídos
renacieron con más brotes y las aves
regresaron con sus trinos y sus nidos
conviviendo con hacheros compartiendo un
destino
el respeto era mutuo entre el monte y el
hachero manteniendo en equilibrio los
recursos del primero más los hombres sin
piedad' lo atacaron nuevamente esta vez
con topadoras hasta el borde de la
muerte
desde entonces los sonidos que se
escuchan en el monte son de angustia y
de dolor
apagados por motores
nadie escucha
tantos gritos de animales espantados ni
tampoco los quejidos de un planeta
colapsando o si escuchan es peor porque
nadie hace nada
mientras el monte agoniza continúan con
la tala y se suma esta inconsciencia los
incendios forestales que también
reinicia el hombre por quemar sus
pastizales los sonidos desde el monte
son de fuego crepitando golpeteos contra
el suelo de animales espantado luego
luego llueve desde el cielo
y amanece todo en calma con insectos
zumbadores aire puro y esperanza
también buena con sus trinos pajaritos
en bandadas que dibujan arco iris un
regalo para el alma es entonces cuando
el monte agobiado de dolor mira el cielo
suplicando
elevando una oración ojalá no vuelva el
hombre con sus máquinas ruidosas y la
vida en este monte siga siendo melodiosa
pero
pero llegan desde lejos
los sonidos de motores poco a poco van
tapando a los pájaros cantores de
rodillas sigue el monte implorando se
detenga basta dice entre sollozos
protejamos lo que queda pide el monte en
su plegaria a dios padre lo proteja de
su agónico destino castigado y sin
fuerza ojalá que dios lo escuche ya que
el hombre se hace el sordo
inconsciente y egoísta destruyéndonos a
todos gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]